Ethel is with us in Long Island hi Ethel
how are you okay Dave I just want to let
you know that I did call you eight years
ago and I paid off my mortgage I did
because I had a little bit of an
inheritance and I paid it but I'm still
in my house I'm divorced and I had seven
hundred thousand dollars in retirement
funds and I don't I'm doing a lot of
reading lately and it doesn't seem like
that's enough and also I looked at the
rule like you take the age 100 and you
subtract your age which minus 70 and you
shouldn't have more than 30% I get sup
stocks in your portfolio and mine rule
that's an idiot okay all right well I I
had I was an idiot for a long time I
during the boom years the last three
years I had all my retirement funds and
CDs and I changed it to Vanguard in
February and now he had it there for a
couple of weeks and then the Cova thing
happened and I lost a tremendous amount
but I have it all back now oh it's back
so you didn't tell you know you wrote it
out I did smart good job local good job
yes well I didn't sleep for a couple of
weeks but I did why do that but now I'm
wondering I have pre-election jitters I
don't want to get too political but if
President Trump doesn't win I'm afraid
that the market may not do so well and
I'm afraid of the same thing happening
another died and I'm wondering if I
should cash out now since I have
everything that I have or what I should
do
you know I hurt I've been on the air
almost 30 years and I've heard that
every election you know this one seems a
little different it's different the
players are dif
yeah well I was during the Obama year so
I was I was an unhappy I was a had a lot
of trepidation I'll put it that way for
things closing on Long Island and I just
thought I don't know and I'm very
concerned yeah well whether you agree
with someone's politics or not if you
look at the historic ride of the stock
market as an investment it really other
than occasional blips here or there has
not necessarily followed a party okay it
actually boomed under Bill Clinton it
boomed under Ronald Reagan it dove under
Ginnie Jimmy Carter so I mean they're
they can they can do things to screw it
up but they really have to work at it to
screw it up because this economy is just
more robust than who's in the White
House and now can they do things to make
the business climate more friendly to
make money in business which helps the
stock market go up yes they can do all
of that but it's not a guarantee what
happens in your house is and you know
the bottom line is people are going to
still go to Home Depot regardless of
who's in the White House they're still
going to buy an iPhone regardless of
who's in the White House they're still
going to do whatever and those companies
make that money so I don't disagree with
the concern about our nation and the
lack of character among anyone that is
running anywhere ever but the but I
don't disagree with you on that but but
I wouldn't freak out about that now if
you want to be a little bit more
conservative in your portfolio that's
fine
but no I would not have 30 percent and
mutual fine you're healthy and vital at
70 there's a strong chance statistically
you're gonna live to 90 and if you yeah
my father just he died and he was 92
there we go all right so the thing is
you got you got 20-some odd years in 30
years that you're going to ride the
market and so this idea
even after that you know your heirs will
and so it's I I think you're fine and
when I am your age I will be 100%
invested in the market in terms of in
terms of mutual fund purchases I won't
be sitting in cash and bonds and this
other crap that these people put out
well daven that's why it's really
important to have that that smart
investor pro in your corner that you can
have a conversation with talk about
these things in a rational way or an
irrational way either way you're getting
opportunity to get some wisdom injected
into whatever your politics might be you
know it's a good point cuz you got
someone at the grand like she's got
you're sitting down with your smart
mister pro and they can walk you through
the trend line of exactly what I'm
talking about
mm-hmm where you saying okay you
remember when you thought Bill Clinton
was gonna bring into the universe is
number one you thought Ronald Reagan was
gonna bring in whichever your
politicians were and you can look at it
and the trend lines just don't follow
your fears no it really doesn't
and you're you're investing will follow
your intention and so you want to have a
plan but it's good to have the
conversation and to be able to see it
but you know for goodness sakes do not I
checked out of the market it's just it's
unnecessary and it's costly financially
to be honest well the news cable news
you just cannot use that as your
investment no your investment adviser
needs to be someone to show you actual
historic data and then you say okay yeah
I think this is crazier than it was back
then
okay so add a crazy factor to it but
it's still not gonna say the world is
gonna come to an end that's right
markets going to dive you know as as o
open phones I can't even think about
what to say is just yeah it's it's
horrible what could happen into in
society yes but but the truth has been
the over the 30 years I've done this and
even when you look back further than
than that in the trend lines the truth
has been that what happens in your house
is ninety something percent of the
equation not what happens in the White
House that's right and so quit trying to
elect someone to fix your life or being
afraid that someone's going to destroy
your life that's going to be affected
they just don't have the
power unless you give it to him that's
right that's exactly right we do we live
in a Democratic Society with checks and
balances and ultimately you need a
budgeting plan in your own you need an
emergency savings plan in your own you
need a plan for your future and you need
a spending plan and those things are
very realistic and those are things that
we can control yeah but I'm not gonna
stop buying real estate no I'm not gonna
stop buying good growth stock mutual
funds over a long period of time in my
401k I'll turn 60 here shortly and so
I'm gonna continue to do that I'm not
gonna stop doing the things that got me
here that's right because of who goes
into the White House that's where I
agree it may or may not do better or may
or may not do worse but it's not going
to substantially change staying
sidelining yourself and going into CDs
cost you a lot more than those guys
being elected could cost you yes that's
what we're gonna learn to